der band ja hallo meine lieben freund
und herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren folge hunger games zusammen mit
dem den amc da hier direkt neben mir
steht und da hat irgendeiner in chat
geschrieben dass er mich kennt also wird
wahrscheinlich eine interessante runde
loslaufen
jetzt weiß man sicher durch graben kann
lauft lauft freien ringreiter ohne
scheiß wieso ist ein typ schon in der
mitte freue ich mich auf victoria
entscheidet das recht ich wollte die
mitte aber nicht sagen
der junge bin praktisch tot weil ihm ein
termin mich schlägt podolski schlägt
mich was für ein kleiner junge der kilt
mich auch lackiert mich auch wenn ich
nicht ganz wirklich kommt nicht gut weg
ich hab ihn abgehängt was wollen ob er
ehrlich wo bist du bist du wohl wisse
dass erstmals ein eigenes glauben ja
auch irgendwie weg man ich habe ein
bisschen was zu essen auf jeden fall ein
paar interessante sachen was gekriegt
damit kriegt man immer war
normalerweise bei den anderen nicht so
bei mir ist ein rätsel
scheiß alter der band stone nein
schlag mich nicht alter power system her
wenn mir leuchtet alles was hier los
fragte von krippen hier nein glaube ich
mich auch noch nein hilfe ok bei mir das
auch ein rein kommen nicht rein
osterhasen costa 18 9 podolski irgendwas
kommt und die hat eine rüstung so was er
denn so erfolgt auch eine schlägt mich
erschreckt mich einfach ist es stark ich
bin talal al alam
29 nur weil er uns erkannt hat darum
läuft uns hinterher was für ein mongole
herrlich war das der ja der hat
geschehen den alten computer und das
nervt richtig beginn extra auf
amerikanische server und auf einmal
erkennt man uns das gesteht auch ist
schrecklich ich bin echt grad die ganze
hätten am springen mit idealzeit leute
daher laufen
ich habe die kiste nix drin ist gerade
nicht lebte er noch näher an der kommt
schon wieder der opfer hängst du denn
ja ich bin jetzt gleich tot weil ich
keine waffe haben kein leben habe unter
ihm ankommt oder oder sicherlich lebt
noch und bin ganz alleine dass es jetzt
mittlerweile gut ich habe sogar was zu
essen und alles ich gehe eh schon genug
halt nur einnahmen sind nicht so gut
lesen kann dies irgendwann einfach
irgendwo alter drücken kann
und ich weiß nicht ob man das öffnen
kann die abwechselnd drückt hier aber
wohl nicht bei mir gar nicht überall nur
nahm der hinten verfolgt mich dahin am
york hat wieder namen gesehen war das
einfach nur weglaufen
mich haben immer noch keine einzige
waffe geil alter ich habe eine kiste mit
schwer möglich
scheiß podolskis von hinten angelaufen
der fahrzeug nur sein opfer fühlt sich
ganz gut ich bin in der aufnahme von
einem coach huber nee nee nee mole so
läuft sie nicht
ich laufe jetzt ein paar sprinter
schnurgerade aus wo ich hoffe sonst
lande angelaufen kommt nicht laufe
zickzack aber ich glaube ich kann gleich
gar nicht mehr sprechen
nein
irgendwas berührt ich kann jeden moment
ich merke das ja einer kommt ich höre
dass ich höre das nicht aber ich weiß
dass hinter mir jetzt so einem angola
nicht gut absolut nicht gut nicht gut
nicht gut
ich höre dass hinter mir und ich kann
ich mir sprint herzlich wehgetan
runtergefallen ist arbeiten schwer hatte
ich nicht ich bin am arsch bern am 8 ich
hab richtig geile sache mittlerweile
okay ich bin tot
ok ich mal schwer als wer hat denn das
geschafft das schwert kaputte sei und
der kaum mehr sprinten
wir haben ein halbes jahr dort kann auch
sprint ich weiß es nicht genau ich
glaube erst du mich zu treffen was war
erlaubt ist was sollen das für eine
bessere sachen als ich okay gut ich habe
volles leben voller hunger dingens ein
schwert ein helm ja du bist du auch das
volles leben schwert und helm 35 minuten
als 30 minuten lange helfe so schwer wie
das schwert und helm habe ich allerdings
gesehene natur oh das wasser ich glaube
das was du denn hier direkt hinter der
ich sehe kein das sind ruhe
war doch klar schon wieder leer ja da
vorne sind welche zwei stück wo panzer
oder die machen team ist bestimmt ein
team das ist blöd da kommt eine an woher
die entgegen under also etwa 2 gegen 2
uhr aus einer lage die beiden sind die
kämpfen
ja ich dachte bei mir doch bitte hier
kommt eine an mit diamant irgendwas oder
das sei nicht gerade hoch sollte er mich
eigentlich nicht mehr sehen erklärte
hast du hoch da ich muss irgendwie
anders hier hoch kommen so geht das
nicht was ich für moves rausholen
jetzt zeige ich auch mit auf ja
natürlich die zuschauer von denen
sondern hier noch hoch und ganz oben
komme ich bestimmt gar nicht hoch doch
aber ich hab kein bock das reicht nach
das alter ist wenn ich viel zu weit oben
hier ist nicht nur was ja toll was hat
mit das herz gebrannt sitzt er hier ist
die kiste wo denn der direkt unter die
affäre andersrum andersrum
nein andersrum hinter dir man hier auf
boden jetzt darauf und jetzt hier auf
dem boden gucken hier andere ich doch
nicht alter anderen ja auch nix drin was
kann er nicht war seine dann springen in
den tod wie können die rettung mehr
wenn es noch ein haus da will ich
irgendwie hin
so kann ich mich ein bisschen zum haus
lotsen gerade wenn möglich bitte wenn
die fresse ich hab ich auch alleine ich
hab sogar ich habe gold und alles
mögliche aber keiner doch ich habe zwei
pfeile geil zwei pfeile bringen mal
sowas von gar nichts war der angel
ich glaube nicht mal mit zwei der charts
bringt das wird ist man tot kommt auf
die rüstungen auch bei nichts rüstung
nicht wenn ich sage nicht dann heißt es
auch nicht interessant wäre irgendwo
noch eine kiste versteckt mal ein
bisschen mit rumfliegen hier mir wo du
bist
spector der konkurrent was freunde wir
wahrscheinlich soll die schlangen jetzt
bin ich woanders geiger oper 12 luca
sandstein 1 operator svk in herborn 4 3
1 2 3 gamer von chart 1 2 luke drei
gewand jede mark 11 347 carey berrys ex
lewis 38 3 die kommen noch so nahm und
podolski 141 morgengold airbus 380 11
998 airbus ist das nicht so der
hersteller
versehentlich flugzeughersteller airbus
ist ein flugzeug hersteller jack on
crafter du bist so intelligent design
bisschen verspätet da denkt immer dass
alle hinter mir ist ja wenn auch hinter
dir hast du oder ich laufe ich kann er
pilze nehmen bringt nicht viel
naja so pauschale dan akerson schaller
man dann schon mal nur noch rote betrieb
der gestarteten wieder durchgehend bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
und ich gibt es einen chat ein spectator
nicht auf falsche richtung nachts
mächtig da muss ich hin
gegner der typ echten namen gesehen das
war kurz vor schluss in die richtung wo
ich gucke und gucken was da für sachen
hat ja wenn ich ihn sehen würde
ich stehe nämlich gerade ist ich sehe
nur die dudar einläufst aber jetzt nicht
mehr drin und auch nicht auf der anderen
seite so weit nicht das sehen kann ist
dabei eigentlich welcher bekannten namen
gesehen da oben ist jemals bist du jetzt
zu da kann ich nicht durch geringen
viele rote pilze soll das hochkommen
wenn deines machine brauchst auch rote
und braune
ich finde ich noch irgendwo anders und
ich möchte gerne erstmal den typen töten
töten töten typ typen typen werde ich
durch durchs wasser herbeisehnen ich ja
keine ahnung ich sehe noch nicht also
nicht mehr ich habe den grat gesehen es
bringt uns jetzt noch derselbe viel
das waren wird dem wasser bist du diesen
schinken teilchen da mehr schenkt
media.de nichts glaubt der ist hier
irgendwie nicht mehr
er ist von uns gegangen den server
gelüftet post ag ds possible hier ist
jemand was die hatte ich zu seiner
veranstaltung also wo er hat er gute
sachen
ich sehe muss erst mit eingang finden
vor seinem haus das in so einen
komischen aus trend positiv ein
hier ein ja der 8 der hat ja also das
heißt er hat eine eisen ist ein
holzschwert glaube ich und eineinhalb
leder halbeisen rüstung oder hübscht
einrichtung bekommt ihr ein kann das
sein
ja hier oben hier in der 1
bis zum creative das ist alles ein
bisschen heller euro dort ist der name
ach du scheiße den punch wird der band
ja das war nur zwei schläge oder so vor
ganz alter kurz aufzulaufen bitte ja das
sagt wirklich an dir weil du dann fliegt
man immer ein bisschen über mir da drin
ist doch noch jemand eines bis zu
schloss aber schnell dass bei ihm wie
hoch vorstellen wer auf dem fliegen von
anstrengendem einem messer immer noch
kisten sein
ich glaube nicht oder er hatte sich
schon mal sachen wo durchgeführte lebt
immer noch wenig chancen
ja ich bin ein freund ich könnte mir ich
habe einen berg war kaputt
den kann ich ja noch mal benutzen
sonst kann ich gehe jetzt wieder raus
könne noch zehn leute übrig noch ein
leute übrig hat einer dabei gemacht
höchstwahrscheinlich war okay ich laufe
jetzt aber das war es was ich meinte
sondern ich meinte ein anderes das war
noch weiter weg aber ich meinte das haus
sondern jemand war
hier ist jemand wenn jetzt weiter zurück
in die stadt gestern liegt einer
unterricht auf dem boden rollt blog
warum auch immer
irland ja ich sehe ich sehr sehr ihn das
war einer der ersten der hat okay ich
habe getötet mit dem falschen sachen
geil ich kann mir alter alter vater
jetzt geht es aber aktuell hier vorne
ist reine gewesen
flint ich habe feuerzeug searching mir
ein paar interessante mario hofer kurzen
eisen schwert ich kann mir noch eine
suppe machen
exciting ja manchmal musst du alter
herumzulaufen man das schlaufe gar nicht
warum ich spiele weit weg von dir mitten
in der luft kann ich nicht sagen auch
sonst jetzt noch eine suppe machen
und noch eine für die zukunft auf die
zukunft so geil dass ich mich jetzt so
hochgearbeitet hat finde ich richtig
cool wie viele leute leben noch europe
bekannt nicht 8 glaube ich also wann
wird s mal aufgeführt am spawn steht
dass da mit glaubt er steht ein
erstlingswerk passiert wurde dann stets
erst im spiel selber drin steht nichts
also noch nicht gucke mal ob er beim
spawn jemand ist hier war aber noch eine
kiste die ist auch wieder das steht
sogar noch einen kuchen eschborn sind
zwei leute die dadurch sogar noch einen
kuchen alter legal ist und hier sind
sogar über noch sachen drin mit fleisch
und so da kann ich mir wieder was braten
alter wie geil ist das denn wenn ihr
wollt
offen ist nur am spot klar ist doch
sonst rufen wenn jetzt auch noch offen
ist wie von alles lief mit den leuten
hier war nix glaube ich hier ist eine
kiste auch nochmal apfel und tief drin
ist alter wie ich ab gehe wie ich sie
nie voll geil ist sogar noch offen ach
ist das schön
ich habe nicht mehr kohle ach scheiße
ich kann damit setzt links verbraten
fällt auf schön dann hab ich mal auf
sticks noch sieben leute schauen zuerst
noch dabei leute das doch eine schöne
runde
nein ist voll doof ja weil so ein
podolski mich verfolgt und dann
trochowski
ja ich hoffe ich mal bei denen zwei
hinterher dann bin ich auf youtube
ich glaube klar dass allein aus protest
dagegen nicht hoch angegeben dann alles
gegeben
wann kommt das video mit mir auf youtube
und dann kann alles ist irgendwie nicht
gekommen
hdw gaarden hier etc aus dass true story
sind ja echt in merkwürdigen orten die
morgenpost so ich glaube jetzt einfach
richtung spawn wieder
ja ich schwebe mal über dir ja ich merke
schon schnell
nein du kannst du gar nicht mehr sicher
dass ich wünsch weber aus 38 meter über
die ganze liste
wie komme ich da irgendwie hinweis er
das schmucke mal du kannst auch hier
eine seite bestimmt im buch retter
milliarden glaubt dass ihr sieht richtig
aus mir da war ich bin schon jemand
darum darum nein noch mal lief und ich
geb dir schlief ich kann mir noch gold
wert machen willst gebiet wurde was gold
wert besser als eisenkugeln es nicht ich
bin google so was weiß man einfach noch
mal hatten die nicht in crafting table
gehen die mitte es hat niemand
gesprochen crafting table ja in der
mitte schon lauf schnell hin gerade ist
niemand der welt bestimmt wieder welche
kommentierten die ammann schwerter
moment ist niemand da ich werde ich auch
rechtzeitig waren wenn du jemand kommt
im moment ist niemand da auch nicht mal
mehr im umkreis die laufen dann alle rum
siehst du die mitte ja ich bin direkt
auf dem weg ist guter story man das ja
gut dann würden sich einfach richtig
rechtlichen neiße sachen richtig geil
ich würde mich trotzdem bayern weil ja
mit sicherheit noch bessere jetzt
wirklich diamant sachen aber moment sehe
ich so nicht
oder war das nur ein liegt
okay gut ich schaue mal ne moment kommt
ihr mann ist noch leer aber hier liegt
ein goldhelm die allesamt als auch ich
würde mit kräften weil die sicherheit
irgendwann zurückkehren und dann weil
die anfälle auch jemand herum fliegen
auch bei sachen was ist besser jetzt
gold sachen oder diese anderen komischen
teile das weiß ich nicht mal ich glaube
die anderen gold sonne geht auf
ja du ich höre hier so komische
geräusche ach ja noch so dass plate ich
möchte erstmal paar sachen weg die ich
nicht brauche aber mit denen die anderen
auch nichts anfangen können irgendwie
kommt hier niemand vielleicht ist ja
irgendwo noch was drin gelassen wenn ein
geradezu auf gefüllte kisten aber seems
like notiz im moment das wäre jetzt
kistler aufgefüllt weil jemand jetzt
bogen wäre ich habe aber schon ein paar
pfeile noch einen pfeil ist im moment
schwierig gucken wo die überhaupt sind
einem haus voller weg ja wie guck mal
bei mir so um ein älteren waldgegend
eines majors seit einer ist hier mal
sehen ist es nach dem spawn dass auf
jeden fall eine stadt wo relativ nah
beim spot läuft auch weg von spawn oder
zumindest nicht direkt hin
und einer ist außerhalb meinung wie
sollte vettel zwei sind im tunnel sind
airbus und podolski die die sogar gleich
welche tonne der hier drin vielleicht
ich weiß nicht ja das ist richtig
weitläufig das gebiet down lesser rein
und dann rechts und dann müssen
irgendwie nochmal recht gleich aber es
kann seine ewig dauert bis es kann sich
runter eigentlich irgendwie schien noch
runter und trocken
naja das nihil lang hier das
unterbewusste zurück wo wert ist wenn
dann hierunter gewusst ich werde ich ja
nicht mal der traum zurück sage ich
einfach nach hinten setze ich lese ja da
hätte es auch unter gekonnt arbeitet ist
auch ein weiter wenn du jetzt nach
rechts guckst du noch ein loch da ist
duschen runter gekonnte auf mich zu ach
du scheiße ich guck mal ob das ob es
okay ist wenn du drauf gest aber es sind
auf jeden fall schon mal zwei egal die
aufnahme werde schon längst an
die am gold und die haben schwert jetzt
hierher zurück jetzt kommt andre otto
das wird knapp das schaffst du nicht das
schaffe ich auch nicht nur der häufig
weg ich weglaufen tue ich jetzt auch
wieviel leben herrscht noch die springen
der soll dort den meisten lampen
außerdem dass du nichts können ist ein
manko ist das laufjahr junge mit einer
taste kritik du hast nichts auf waren
laut über weitere direkter wird ich sag
dir wurde hoch kannst oder so ich weiß
ich hab einfach mal weiter und hoffe
dass jemand kein drama wenn tor eine
gute möglichkeit zum skaten hast weil im
tunnel werden sie doch genau der gülle
voll geschwindigkeit folgen
scheiße der journalist hatte ich kopf
tor doch als die kunst links hier hoch
links wenn ihr jetzt links guckst du
geht's direkt auf eine tolle idee auf
miert es geschafft ich habe endlich
geschafft ding auch fest dass während 60
sekunden gewesen bis zum death match on
einfach scheiße naja egal war eine
interessante lange hunger games runde
und ich würde einfach mal sagen ich bin
raus ich würde mich freuen wenn ihr das
video bewertet kommentar schreiben und
so weiter das war's mit den 1